et nous sommes justement avec un michel
beaugas secrétaire confédéral au secteur
de l'emploi et des retraites du syndicat
fo bonjour merci d'être en direct avec
nous cette réforme des retraites semble
être donc une priorité pour bruno le
vert en tout cas l'année prochaine
comment est-ce que vous réagissez mais
écoutez bonjour bien évidemment pour
nous c'est pareil ça n'a jamais été leur
d'ailleurs pour la réforme de retraite
tu nous semble que c'est pas le cetc
jamais été le bon moment et a
aujourd'hui c'est surtout pas le bon
moment
la priorité c'est de la sauvegarde des
emplois de l'ensemble des salariés de ce
pays il ya des sujets importants autre
que les retraites notamment par exemple
que vont devenir l'ensemble des
saisonniers de la montagne où ce guide
qui travaillait un peu l'hiver voilà il
ya des sujets le sujet c'est l'emploi et
c'est certainement pas le sujet des
retraites relève les retraites sur le
tapis c'est effectivement réouvrir en
fait un conflit social dont on n'a pas
besoin aujourd'hui puisque l'important
c'est de protéger les citoyens s'occuper
de la crise sanitaire s'occuper de la
crise économique qui suit et qui va
venir et elle va être
elle va être virulente malheureusement
pour beaucoup de salariés il ya qu'à
voir le nom de plans sociaux ils sont
qui sont en cours on est presque 700
plans sociaux donc l'important c'est
d'abord l'emploi et les retraites
eh bien on en discutera pourquoi pas
après 2022 on verra justement le
secrétaire général de la cfdt laurent
berger estime que cette réforme elle
n'est pas envisageable avant les
élections présidentielles vous partager
son avis mais effectivement en tout cas
il faudra
on peut on peut discuter en tout cas
pour nous pour sa force ouvrière le le
système qui existe aujourd'hui peut être
amélioré nous sommes opposés à un
système systémique c'est à dire à une
réforme systémique qui verrait une mise
en place d'un système universel à point
pour nous ça pauvre s'appauvrira les
futurs retraités
donc pour nous c'est qu'il y en ait pas
question mais à l'heure actuelle
effectivement c'est pas le moment de
discuter de cette réforme il faut la
renvoyer je voulais dire ou prochain
quinquennat si elle tout est peut-être
discuter tout comme d'ailleurs la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui doit
être abandonnée il faudra à bordeaux du
ciel leur effort et vous pensez que
l'exécutif à prendre le risque justement
de faire de cette question de la réforme
des retraites une question cruciale pour
les échéances électorales
écoutez il ya effectivement on se les
propos de monsieur le maire s'inscrivent
dans la future campagne présidentielle
voilà chacun se positionne dans ce cadre
on va rentrer dans une période on est à
pratiquement à moins de quinze mois
d'élections présidentielles tout à
chacun et bien aura son petit
commentaire aura des positionnements
politiques
on va tomber dans de la politique
politicienne laissons les retraites pour
le moment telles qu'elles sont et nous
verrons ce sujet bien plus tard et si on
le revoit pas d'ailleurs en tout cas si
on doit en parler on en parle pour
améliorer le système actuel il ya des
choses à faire
j'en conviens mais en tout cas une
réforme telle que le veut le faire un
bon jour et que ferez vous donc ces
ajustements le gouvernement persiste
dans sa ligne de conduite
eh bien écoutez on a pu pourquoi trois
portages que c'est pas tout le
gouvernement
l'artiste quand même il ya quelques
ministres m'enfin moi la ministre avec
qui je discute s'appelle elisabeth
bornes
vous avez rappelé sa position l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales de salariés
aux écrits à 5 go pro b mise pour lui
dire que ce n'était pas le moment de
remettre sur le tapis cette réforme et
l'on lui demandant de la remettre à plus
tard ou de l'abandonner
écoutez le bon sens voudrait que le
gouvernement écoute les partenaires
sociaux parce que même le patronat n'est
pas demandeur
donc il écoute les partenaires sociaux
ils remettent à bien plus tard la
proposition et puis de discussions sur
ces sujets et puis voilà que en fait ce
qu il faut c c'est que c'est le bon sens
qui doit qui doit primer dans ce
cadre-là il bon sens dit ne parlons pas
des retraites aujourd'hui
alors justement on voit une levée de
boucliers au sein de la majorité vous
parliez d'elisabeth bornes aussi qui est
semble se ranger du côté des partenaires
sociaux est ce que c'est réellement de
nature vous pensez à faire avancer le
dialogue social sur cette question ce
dossier particulièrement alors il ajouté
on parle beaucoup à l aube spécial
effectivement moi vous savez notre
organisation en force ouvrière le
dialogue social à dialogue social on
préfère la négociation à la concertation
le dialogue social entre guillemets
discuter ça mène pas ça mène pas très
loin ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on se
concerte et qu'au bout de la
concertation puisque on négocie pas avec
l'état mais qu'au bout de la
concertation et bien les avis soient
partagés sur ce qu'on doit faire ou non
aujourd'hui sur la réforme des retraites
cet avis n'est pas partagé il avait
partagé par personne voilà dix par le
patronat ni par les organisations
syndicales de salariés
quelques membres du gouvernement et
peut-être peut-être les disait souhaite
que cette réforme continue à être portés
alors je vous le dis c'est une question
de bon sens et pas le moment a
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
préserver la santé des travailleurs
préserver la santé des salariés
préserver la santé des français et puis
surtout préserver préserver l'emploi et
c'est pas en laissant les salariés âgés
plus longtemps au travail on développe à
l'emploi des jeunes par exemple
merci beaucoup à vous une chaîne l'ogaas
secrétaire confédéral au secteur de
l'emploi et des retraites du syndicat fo
fa